[Musique]
bienvenue au siège du cabinet towers et
ce maïs je voulais réussir là où ma
famille avait échoué que puis-je pour
vous même je t'ai pas d'or c'est la
banque qui vous mènera laquelle va
tomber d'abord vous êtes viré le
bâtiment est officiellement en
quarantaine
c'est dans ce bâtiment devrait bientôt
présenté les premiers symptômes
gardez votre calme voici le virus y 17
qui principalement s'attaque à notre
inconscient et détruit notre équilibre
mental
les gens infectés par le virus y décède
perdent le contrôle de leur émotion et
ne sont par conséquent pas responsables
de leurs actes c'est notre chance c'est
celle qui t'as foutu dans la merde et
elle est dans les bureaux aux grands
maux les grands remèdes et vient au
boulot
nettoyer en modèle
j'ai transformé en torrent